Well, if you only focus on your brightest students,
you know what happens is disparities grow,
and you can see this bubble moving slightly to the other direction,
but still, an impressive improvement.
A major overhaul of Poland's education
helped to dramatically reduce between variability among schools,
turn around many of the lowest-performing schools,
and raise performance by over half a school year.
And you can see other countries as well.
Portugal was able to consolidate its fragmented school system,
raise quality and improve equity,
and so did Hungary.
So what you can actually see, there's been a lot of change.
And even those people who complain and say that
the relative standing of countries
on something like PISA is just an artifact of culture,
of economic factors, of social issues,
of homogeneity of societies, and so on,
these people must now concede that education improvement is possible.
You know, Poland hasn't changed its culture.
It didn't change its economy. It didn't change
the compositions of its population.
It didn't fire its teachers. It changed its education policies
and practice. Very impressive.
And all that raises, of course, the question: What can we learn
from those countries in the green quadrant
who have achieved high levels of equity,
high levels of performance, and raised outcomes?
And, of course, the question is, can what works in one context
provide a model elsewhere?
Of course, you can't copy and paste education systems wholesale,
but these comparisons have identified a range of factors
that high-performing systems share.
Everybody agrees that education is important.
Everybody says that.
But the test of truth is, how do you weigh that priority
against other priorities?
How do countries pay their teachers
relative to other highly skilled workers?
Would you want your child to become a teacher
rather than a lawyer?
How do the media talk about schools and teachers?
Those are the critical questions, and what we have learned
from PISA is that, in high-performing education systems,
the leaders have convinced their citizens to make choices
that value education, their future,
more than consumption today.
And you know what's interesting? You won't believe it,
but there are countries in which the most attractive place
to be is not the shopping center but the school.
Those things really exist.
But placing a high value on education
is just part of the picture.
The other part is the belief that all children
are capable of success.
You have some countries where students
are segregated early in their ages.
You know, students are divided up,
reflecting the belief that only some children
can achieve world-class standards.
But usually that is linked to very strong social disparities.
If you go to Japan in Asia, or Finland in Europe,
parents and teachers in those countries
expect every student to succeed,
and you can see that actually mirrored in student behavior.
When we asked students what counts
for success in mathematics,
students in North America would typically tell us,
you know, it's all about talent.
If I'm not born as a genius in math, I'd better study something else.
Nine out of 10 Japanese students say
that it depends on my own investment, on my own effort,
and that tells you a lot about the system that is around them.
In the past, different students were taught in similar ways.
High performers on PISA embrace diversity
with differentiated pedagogical practices.
They realize that
ordinary students have extraordinary talents,
and they personalize learning opportunities.
High-performing systems also share
clear and ambitious standards across the entire spectrum.
Every student knows what matters.
Every student knows what's required to be successful.
And nowhere does the quality of an education system
exceed the quality of its teachers.
High-performing systems are very careful
in how they recruit and select their teachers
and how they train them.
They watch how they improve the performances of teachers
in difficulties who are struggling,
and how they structure teacher pay.
They provide an environment also in which teachers work together
to frame good practice.
And they provide intelligent pathways for teachers to grow
in their careers.
In bureaucratic school systems,
teachers are often left alone in classrooms
with a lot of prescription on what they should be teaching.
High-performing systems are very clear what good performance is.
They set very ambitious standards, but then they enable
their teachers to figure out,
what do I need to teach to my students today?
The past was about delivered wisdom in education.
Now the challenge is to enable user-generated wisdom.
High performers have moved on from professional
or from administrative forms of accountability and control --
sort of, how do you check whether people do what they're supposed to do in education --
to professional forms of work organization.
They enable their teachers to make innovations in pedagogy.
They provide them with the kind of development they need
to develop stronger pedagogical practices.
The goal of the past was standardization and compliance.
High-performing systems have made teachers
and school principals inventive.
In the past, the policy focus was on outcomes,
on provision.
The high-performing systems have helped teachers
and school principals to look outwards to the next teacher,
the next school around their lives.
And the most impressive outcomes of world-class systems
is that they achieve high performance across the entire system.
You've seen Finland doing so well on PISA,
but what makes Finland so impressive
is that only five percent of the performance variation
amongst students lies between schools.
Every school succeeds.
This is where success is systemic.
And how do they do that?
They invest resources where they can make the most difference.
They attract the strongest principals into the toughest schools,
and the most talented teachers
into the most challenging classroom.
Last but not least, those countries align policies
across all areas of public policy.
They make them coherent over sustained periods of time,
and they ensure that what they do is consistently implemented.
Now, knowing what successful systems are doing
doesn't yet tell us how to improve.
That's also clear, and that's where some of the limits
of international comparisons of PISA are.
That's where other forms of research need to kick in,
and that's also why PISA doesn't venture into
telling countries what they should be doing.
But its strength lies in telling them
what everybody else has been doing.
And the example of PISA shows that data
can be more powerful than administrative control of financial subsidy
through which we usually run education systems.
You know, some people argue that
changing educational administration
is like moving graveyards.
You just can't rely on the people out there to help you with this. (Laughter)
But PISA has shown what's possible in education.
It has helped countries to see that improvement is possible.
It has taken away excuses from those who are complacent.
And it has helped countries to set meaningful targets
in terms of measurable goals achieved by the world's leaders.
If we can help every child, every teacher, every school,
every principal, every parent see what improvement is possible,
that only the sky is the limit to education improvement,
we have laid the foundations
for better policies and better lives.
Thank you.
(Applause)